you could see how i think heidi in a way
is a proxy for a lot of people broadly
on the left i mean she's actually a
centrist democrat but
where they say well somebody's a nazi
and then it's like no they're not a nazi
they accuse somebody else
of being like the nazis then you know
then it's like well they hang out with
the alt-right then they do this then
they do that and there's almost like
a series of decision trees but it's like
okay not a nazi but then this not this
but then that and
so you know it's a nice encapsulation i
think of a thought process that is
unfortunately
rampant in public discourse right now
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the editor at large of
reason magazine and host of the reason
interview
nick gillespie finally welcome to the
reuben report
thanks for having me dave i really
appreciate it so this is very bizarre
for me to admit but
we played a clip of real time with bill
maher last week with heidi heitkamp
accusing gina carano of basically being
a nazi and a white supremacist and you
were sitting next uh
heidi heitkamp when she said this and i
played the clip
and then i said oh there's my buddy nick
gillespie from reason magazine four i
think i said former guest of the reuben
report
and then we realized after that we've
never done this somehow and i
i feel bad i usually don't apologize at
the beginning of a show
but i feel bad that you've never been
here before i uh in
many contexts i perform after i
apologize after performance
uh failures so i uh uh please don't
apologize i'm happy to be here
i know i've gotten to interview you
twice once for reason and once at uh
students for liberty liberty con
so it's nice to be on the other side of
the mic
all right one way or another here we are
it's overdue
but we got a lot to get to but let's
let's start with that clip because i
want to spend a lot of time obviously
talking about
libertarianism and if there's any
differences between libertarianism and
classical liberalism and
what should libertarians do now and all
that good stuff
but since the clip was what got us here
today let's start with that so i'm going
to throw to it right now
who was the woman in the mandalorian
what did she do she liked something
she was a nazi oh that's different right
i'm thinking of somebody else well she's
not a
nazi she's awake she's look at that you
say you're calling her
she's called other people not right
which is the nazi
okay everyone's a nazi now yeah um she
does hang with white supremacists it's
like a mel brooks
does yeah hangs with whites i suppose
i'm not get subject to defamation
i i don't know i mean it depends on what
your definition of white supremist is
that you're
there changed a lot you should be a guy
in a clan hood who
but i think we have to i think we have
to be really careful there's two things
the republicans think they're going to
get biden on
cancel culture and this whole dr seuss
stuff that's going on where they're
reading
green eggs and ham proving that some of
these senators can actually read
and and um and
and immigration and and and so
we can't ignore the fact that we got
donald trump was in part because of
political correctness
okay so there's obviously a bunch to
unpack there
and it sort of seems to me by the by
your sort of quick reaction
it's like when you're doing this on live
tv sometimes people say
something so over the top you kind of
don't know how to react can you just lay
out what was going through your mind
during that
uh you know it there were a lot of
moments where
um you know i was kind of looking to my
left and i was like i
this is a former you know u.s senator
and i didn't understand where she was
coming from that was certainly part of
it and
uh you know the whole you know i i grew
up in the 70s and 80s and hogan's heroes
and mel brooks movies were still
you know everywhere and they always were
making fun of nazis
i never thought i would live in america
my father in world war ii fought the
nazis i mean he was in the
you know in europe fighting as an
infantryman i never thought
that people would be seriously lobbing
charges of nazism
just as a way of shutting down all sorts
of conversation what i liked in that
clip
or what i liked in the reaction there is
that bill maher
has really stepped up as a massive
defender of free speech and you know and
i disagree with him about a lot of
things i'm sure you do too
but fundamentally what you want in a you
know what you want in
anybody in media certainly and anybody
in any kind of intellectual endeavor to
be pushing for free speech
and i was glad to see him push back in a
way that you know was was refreshing
because
and you could see how i think heidi in a
way is a proxy for a lot of people
broadly on the left i mean she's
actually a centrist democrat but
where they say well somebody's a nazi
and then it's like no they're not a nazi
they accuse somebody else
of being like the nazis then you know
then it's like well they hang out with
the alt-right
then they do this then they do that and
there's almost like a series of decision
trees but it's like okay not a nazi but
then this not this but then that and
so you know it's a nice encapsulation i
think of a thought process that is
unfortunately
rampant in public discourse right now
yeah and you could sort of see the way
she was
laughing and smiling over what she was
saying that she didn't even
believe it or even know what she was
saying in a way i think that second part
is probably more to the point and i have
to say you know i enjoy talking with her
uh you know in in some ways if there
were more democrats
like her still in the senate yeah i
don't think we would be seeing the same
level of spending
et cetera having said that i mean it's a
little bit promiscuous
to you know call somebody a nazi and
then not even know who they are
or what they were talking about and then
you know just kind of trail off into
well you know
maybe they're not nazis but they hang
out with people who hang out with people
who
hang out with nazis who aren't really
nazis um you know
enough already yeah it is enough ready
real quick on
on bill maher because i think he said
something interesting there he is what i
would say is
maybe one of the last 10 public
intellectuals or comedians whatever you
want to call him
that is offering what i would say is a
liberal a true liberal defense of free
speech that
obviously you guys like us are
completely aligned with but my
frustration with him at this point is i
want him to just say at this point he's
a libertarian basically just say it bill
you want a smoke pot
you want to live your life you're a
bachelor at 60 whatever with millions of
dollars and go to the playboy mansion or
whatever is left with it
uh yeah i know is there even a playboy
match with left anymore uh you know yeah
somebody bought it and i don't know
what's going on there but but to me it's
like bill
is this odd thing where he'll bring on
adam schiff and say
you know all my friends are leaving and
california is not not business friendly
but then he'll still support democrats
and i'm struggling with that help me
nick
so you know back in the 90s the first
time i interviewed bill maher for
reason has been around since 1968 i
joined in 1993.
i interviewed bill at some point in the
mid 90s
and he was calling himself a libertarian
then he was not particularly ideological
you know he's not a card-carrying member
i don't think of anything other than
maybe peta to be quite honest but
um what he meant by that was that he was
in favor of free speech he was against
censorship which is a huge thing i mean
people forget in the 90s
janet reno and bill clinton along with
all
you know major republicans like uh bob
dole if you can
anybody remembers him they were all
talking about censoring cable tv for
having too much sex and violence and
you know we were talking about like
basic basic cable
and he pushed back on that he was very
big in favor of free speech in favor of
kind of open sexuality which was kind of
forward back then avant
um and then he i think with bush
uh and then obama and then certainly
trump
he started rolling more with democrats
in terms of economic policy and so
you know i actually think and i'm happy
to talk about this more i think there
is a kind of you know i i consider
myself a libertarian without adjectives
i believe in what reason calls free
minds and free markets i
you know i want choice in everything you
know from abortion
to schools to food to you know marriage
whatever
um and um you know but there are people
on the right who are more
conservative and are libertarian in
spirit or in many policies
people on the left and i think bill
maher is pretty good there
on the left side of things uh and his
really important function now
is you know he is one of the few people
in a kind of you know
major what's now legacy media it's funny
to think that hbo is actually kind of
old school um you know but he was
sticking up for freedom of speech and
freedom of expression
and you know at one point in that show
he was saying like can we hold two
thoughts at the same time that
uh you know for instance that um we were
talking about asian
violence against asians in america and
he was like yeah there could be some of
that coming out of covid
but it's also that the atlanta shooting
was not that
and i like to hear that kind of stuff
you know from whether it's from the
right or the left like people who are
just saying
you know let's have a conversation that
is not simply uh
talking points or or you know slurs like
heidi heitkamp was tossing around
so it sounds to me like you'd kind of
love him to say he was a libertarian
in a way because it would be great for
libertarianism but on another hand he
serves this sort of function
as a as a remaining liberal let's say i
think so yeah and and you know i
again like right left libertarians like
someone sometimes you hear
conservatarians and left libertarians
and
whatever i'm less interested in that and
and the slogans or the labels and i'm
more interested in like when you see
people actually having conversations and
one of the great virtues of his show
i think real time and before that
politically incorrect when it was on ibc
and before that on comedy central
was that it was a staging ground for
people who disagree with each other
getting to air their you know to have a
conversation or even an argument
for more than 30 seconds at a time one
of the things that i think you've done
in a host of other people is really take
advantage of
the space and time that youtube and
other platforms you know the blaze
actually is also
a fascinating network to me because it's
you know the one thing you can't say
about the blaze is that oh you know
they're
they're they're only talking in 15
second sound bites uh you know like cnm
msnbc or fox even you know like these
are
long shows that are taking advantage of
the time and space we have so more power
to bill maher for that
yeah all right so let's move off bill
maher for a moment
i'm going to keep working i'm going to
keep nudging him on my show that's
that's my plan is just to keep
nudging him because it's like the
democrats when they come to cancel him i
said this to him once when they
at an after party at real time i said
you know when they come to get you one
day it's going to be the left not the
right
yeah i think he knows that because i and
i think it was during the show
like a portion of that air because of
covet there were you know fewer gas than
no
after party or anything like that but he
was saying you know that like
when he goes places like people are
often afraid to speak up
even in in private gatherings because if
you don't know everybody i mean it's
it's kind of like everybody's in the
mafia and they're always figuring
there's a couple of
you know federal agents who are
recording everything so you don't say
anything if you don't know everybody
what a what if you know [ __ ] up world
to be living in like where we have
you know some time uh you know since the
early 60s we kicked free of all the
dumbest restraints
on free speech you know government
censorship you could publish
you couldn't uh legally publish lady
chatterley's lover
james joyce's ulysses henry miller's
tropic of cancer
allen ginsberg's howl before about 1960
without worrying about being dragged
into court
we got rid of all of that and then we
created the internet which is like an
infinite you know hard drive where you
can just load up everything you want
and we're arguing now about like you
know policing each other's speech in
such picky you in horrible ways
it's you know it's it's tragic if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell